well seaweed-based feed to reduce
methane emissions in cows it's just like
okay how many levels of scam do you have
to be on to be able to sell people pills
to make their cows fart less I got a
better idea we should get we should make
helmets for cows they go over their
heads and they have a pipe that goes
down right in front of their mouth but
at a good distance away and their butts
and there is a fire so when they burp it
goes and now the cows are breathing fire
that would actually be really cool could
you imagine you're walking down you're
driving down the road and you see a
bunch of cows and the cow looks and goes
we just have to find a way to harness
the power of that methane yeah so you
know what you know I was saying is we
should get a big dome and put it over
the cow pasture so all the methane gets
sucked up and then we used to to warm
our homes that's a really good idea do
you think the pendulum's swinging back
to him absolutely I mean I think the Bud
Light effect is the main it's a Bud
Light was a catalyst and now we see the
Bud Light effect all these companies
panicking over potentially getting
boycott shot you know Netflix lost
millions of subscribers oh yeah it
wasn't just Bud Light this stuff is
happening I think
look you someone like me right grew up
in Chicago moderately liberal individual
traditional uh socially liberal person
I see a pride parade I go whatever I see
pride flags and stuff I'm like oh that's
cool I have friends who wave the pride
flag and I'm my good friend I'm glad
you're happy man congratulations I uh
I'm I'm fairly liberal in the
traditional Sense on issues of gay
marriage and uh families and all that
stuff and I've had arguments with
conservatives on these on these issues
and we get along but we disagree
then all of a sudden I start seeing them
send books like genderqueer to kids
which have overt sex acts in them from
an author who outrights says in the book
that she has sexually aroused the
thought of being a man and then wants
children to say affirm her as a man I'm
like I'm putting together two and two
together here
yeah they're grooming kids right now all
of a sudden I'm like hey can we not do
this and what happens they attack me
they call me a conservative
so this is this is the point where
people like me who are traditionally
liberal are now hanging out with
conservatives and the simple way to put
it is this I am I am beset on both sides
by activists
on the on the right there was a man
saying I think abortion is wrong life
begins a conception and we should not be
killing these babies and I say okay well
there's a lot of challenging questions
there around the rights of of two
individuals now who are sharing one body
and how we deal with that but uh I hear
your argument right then I look to my
left and they say anyone for any reason
at any time should be allowed to abort
the baby even if the baby can can
survive and I say that has no logic and
makes literally no sense in any capacity
if the baby must be delivered from the
woman no matter what why kill the baby
they made this argument about like what
if the baby's stillborn what's on
abortion then if the baby's already dead
well what if the mother's health is in
Jeopardy I agree the baby must be
removed I'm sorry if the baby would
survive abortion specifically defined by
by the federal government planned
Paradise ending the life of that baby so
what ends up happening is a person like
me who has traditionally been pro-choice
says if the only options you're giving
me is we ban abortion outright or we
allow babies just did it at nine months
to be killed I'm gonna vote for the guy
who's Banning abortion because I'm like
it may not fit my worldview perfectly
but man that's graphic and psychotic and
they're doing it in so many states now
we come to the question of child sex
changes look you take a look at what's
going on in Europe you take a look at
Finland and you know better than I do
they are shutting this stuff down the
research isn't backing it up and so I
say okay well you know the best
assumption I can make is clearly this
doesn't make sense uh it's not working
and you look at desistance rates these
studies that we've said in the show
several times show what is it 65 to 95
of children desist and live happy normal
lives so there's an important thing
about that statistic this is based off
all the studies up until about 2004
before they started giving kids puberty
blockers so these studies and there's
about 12 academic ones that have been
done I'll point to you over 80 on
average
of these kids desisted but this is when
one out of 30 000 were affected and then
go through puberty this yeah and they'd
go through puberty puberty itself was
The Cure yep now we're blocking the Cure
but this is real gender dysphoria this
affected mostly boys not girls most grew
up to be gay what we're seeing today
totally different mostly adolescent
girls they're all going to grow up to be
fun so here's my point yeah well not if
they carve whatever whatever argument
the left wants to make about their views
on these issues
something maybe I could potentially
agree with let's say they're like we
want to
um tax the rich
and I'm like oh man you know I don't
know it's universal healthcare we want
to create a public option and I'm like
there's a lot of questions about that
but I'm not you know as polarized on
that issue and they say vote for us and
we will create Universal basic health
care won't cover very expensive Cancer
Treatments but it'll cover your flus
your broken bones and I'm going okay
that sounds pretty good and they go and
by the way we're going to give children
sex changes and we're gonna abort babies
at nine months I'll be like I'm gonna go
vote for the other guy and the other guy
says no health care for anyone but at
least babies will live and I'll be like
I gotta take what I can get I guess well
what you just said is what's called
Obamacare right well that's what
happened under Obamacare then they were
mandated to pay for these child sex
changes and I think that went into
effect in 2015 and surprise surprise
that's also a year that started
skyrocketing now it's not just Obamacare
that's the year that Bruce Jenner became
Caitlyn Jenner yep and I believe it's
the year I am Jazz became a reality show
that might have started earlier but
that's helped to popularize this it's
been Jazz how long has it been on TV
it's like uh maybe it's longer than that
no maybe nine or ten years almost so
there's been breaks around there 2015.
but but there you go oh okay 2015's a
yeah eight okay but Michael you're in
all of this my uh my my my my my
statement is very simply when it comes
to liberals look man
I I would vote for like a moderate you
know I would prefer someone who's
moderate for for me I can understand the
arguments coming from conservatives we
have sane rational logical arguments I
often cite the conversation I have with
Glenn Beck on abortion that was I
thought wonderful and ended with a
handshake smiles and we'll learn to live
together and try and find the best way
to build a great America and I'm like
this is fantastic and it was friendly
and it was great and I have tremendous
respect for him and then we have these
people on the show and these leftists
who will say things like I'm for forced
abortion like nonsensical I I met this
Earth said that I don't think trans
people exist and I said who who are you
talking to yeah I was like what do you I
I absolutely think trans people exist I
don't what does that mean what are you
saying you think they don't exist I'm
like you're not you're just saying words
doesn't mean anything it means nothing
means literally nothing to me I I have
trans friends I think trans people exist
I want them to have civil rights I want
to be protected I just think we're
talking about kids here and it's a
different question so if my option is
that or a conservative guy at least the
conservative guy makes sense well and
this is how happened on the show where
I've had this conversation with
left-wing guests and I have explained
that I do not use the made up pronouns I
call somebody a reality based pronouns
based on what they are and they were
saying wait so like you don't think
trans people exist conservatives don't
think trans people exist no I recognize
that there are human beings who exist
who identify as the opposite sex I'm
saying that doesn't actually make them
the opposite sex what is this slogan you
you're debating their right to exist
what no I can't I can't stop them from
existing with my words I can only
accurately identify what they are and
say I'm not willing to lie they say this
because it silences conversation yep
because it shuts people up it's the same
reason they say kids are going to kill
themselves if you don't let them
transition but here's the deal it's a
label right now an adult can take on
whatever label they want
but the way we should be framing this
especially with kids is there are
children with gender dysphoria or I
would prefer the word sexist for you but
whatever right there are children who
are struggling there's these are
children in distress half of them are on
the autism spectrum all these kids have
some other mental health comorbidity
going on they need to be screened for
trauma and abuse because that's very
common a lot of these girls and some of
the boys too have been sexually abused
some of these kids have come up to me
and told me stories there's always
something going else something else
going on and I don't want anyone to
believe me I want everyone to go onto
Google right now and look up a story by
Jamie Reed an article published by Jamie
Reed in the Free Press she worked at the
Washington University transgender Clinic
connected to St Louis Children's
Hospital she describes herself as a
queer woman who's married to a trans man
and she's politically left of Bernie
Sanders I didn't know that was possible
but she filed an affidavit with the
Attorney General of Missouri and she
wrote this devastating expose where she
confirms everything that people like
myself have been saying can I actually
wanna I wanna point something out so
recently we got news that Starbucks was
taking down the pride decorations this
came from the Starbucks Workers Union
and I posted about it and I had a bunch
of leftists tell me that I'm wrong
that I was hoaxed that the right is
pushing fake news and my response was
how did it come to be that the
quote-unquote left would side with the
corporation's spokesperson over their
workers union
it's wild it's probably tribal like they
just had literally used it's probably
it's no no it's because the idea that
they would lose a culture War battle is
more important than the fact and I'm
like
you know the thing me siding with the
workers union is on brand right I'm not
a big fan of unions but of course we
often side on the more populist side of
things the left tends to decide on the
corporatist side of things yet they're
supposed to be the ones that are working
for the workers it clearly just makes no
sense yeah they're the anti-fascists
they'll tell you they're not the ones
that are pushing the lucrative merger of
a state and all the corporations for the
record on this Starbucks thing Workers
Union said Starbucks is pulling trans
stuff Starbucks corporate said no we're
not and then there's video of specific
stores removing there's videos of
employees complaining they're being
forced to take down Pride decorations
but they're not saying it's by corporate
necessarily it's by middle management oh
they're saying corporate sent an issue
well I mean I don't think anyone gets
that specifically they're saying I was
told I had to take these things down so
it might just be and then the workers
micromanagement the workers union said
that there that across the country
they've been instructed numerous stores
have been instructed to remove their oh
and corporate denied it and then
corporate denied there is no policy to
take these things down cool I don't
believe the corporate spokesperson like
when Deepwater Horizon happened and the
BP is like we're sorry I'm like yeah you
guys are full of it right I don't
believe when Fukushima happened and the
Japanese you know government they're
saying like everything's gonna control
like no you're lying right
what makes more sense a bunch of workers
were told to do a thing they filmed
videos about it they said it's happening
probably happening
but now you have the left on the side of
the massive multinational corporation so
no no they they never never said that
they're keeping it up it's like okay
whatever dude thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time